c'est dieu c'est dur c'est dur d'avoir
20 en 2009 c'est
[Musique]
je m'appelle matile j'ai 22 ans et je
suis actuellement étudiant en première
année de psychologie
je suis né prématuré
j'ai manqué d'oxygène à la naissance qui
fait que j'ai des problèmes d'équilibré
il ya des troubles associés aussi j'ai
des difficultés à me repérer dans
l'espace une certaine lenteur dans les
gestes comme pour écrire événement qui a
plus de mal que l'autre divergence entre
les versions c'est compliqué de faire le
rythme de l'écriture et le sûr avec le
rythme de la preuve ce n'est pas
toujours évident du coup on apprenait ce
de notes avec qui me prend les courants
ils sont rémunérés pour mon problème à
telus partie de notre promo le coc vide
ça complique et ça arrange certaines
choses le distancer ça m'apporte tout
apaisement là au niveau de mes cours au
niveau logistique au niveau transport ça
m'a permis de ne pas avoir cette
contrainte en plus ce qui est souvent
problématique parce que on avait fait à
mahalla bonheur et tout ça est au niveau
négatif bas s'enlève de la
sociabilisation et et pour nous c'est
encore plus dur parce que on a déjà du
mal à se déplacer donc si on voit plus
le monde qui nous entoure c'est
compliqué
[Musique]
ouais je sais la chine à se faire
maintes éviter les raiders et d'avoir
des douleurs porto et c'est plus souple
en fait et pour mes marché se sentir
mieux dans son corps au premier
confinement jeunes avait patiné la cité
dur par rapport à d'autres amis qui sont
dans ma situation moi j'ai une chance
c'est que je suis entouré par mon papa
maman j'ai un grand frère aussi ça a
pris un an et demi que je suis avec rémy
et franchement j'ai beaucoup de chance
il m'aide au quotidien que ce soit dans
les bombes dans les mauvais moments
je trouve qu'on se complète parce que
lui il boit pas et moi je mange pas et
en fait des fois c'est moi qui suit ses
yeux et lui les mélanges été séduit par
son courage sa force
bon après il ya bien des moments de
doute mais ça enfin je veux dire dans le
handicap c'est courant mais ça empêche
pas d'avancer ses actionnaires chez elle
non non ça va mieux mais il ya une
époque que le regard des autres était
très compliqué pour moi et aussi je
manque beaucoup de confiance en moi et
je pensais tu joues handicapés au regard
des autres parce que en fait ce qu'est
ce qui m'énerve un peu est ce que
j'essaie de de valoriser c'est que c'est
pas parce qu'on a un handicap et qu'on
peut rien faire dans 20 ans je me vois
psychologue alors à des enfants avec
rémy espère et continuer mon combat
parce que partir seule avance mais je
peux attendre que la vente pour faire
les choses c'est dommage de passer à
côté de sa vie parce que on a un
handicap
[Musique]